warren cass is the former chief policy
advisor to mitt romney
he believes that the gop should abandon
what he calls free market fundamentalism
arguments against government
interference in the marketplace he says
read like they appeared in an
introductory economics exam
in the real world theories like
imperative advantage bear
no resemblance to how the international
economy operates
cass is the founder and executive
director of the think tank american
compass
he participated in a recent soho forum
debate
arguing that if the u.s is going to
remain competitive
washington must aggressively intervene
to aid the manufacturing sector
arguing against cass was scott linceco a
senior fellow at the cato institute who
says that in the real
world government interference has only
hurt manufacturing
lindsey combs says that the problem with
the economic nationalism favored by cass
is that it insulates companies from the
discipline
of profit and loss in a free market
businesses learn from their mistakes he
says
when the government is involved they
react by growing bigger
as a way to cover for their failures
here are warren cass
and scott lincecum debating what role
the government should play in the u.s
economy
in an online debate moderated by soho
forum director
gene epstein
tonight's resolution reads again to
promote
prosperity among all income groups the
u.s
government should adopt an industrial
policy
defending the resolution orrin cass
executive director of american compass
and author of
the once and future worker a vision for
the renewal of
work in america opposing scott
lindsacombe of the cato institute
welcome
to you both uh scott and oren
i'll be keeping the time and will
briefly interrupt
each speaker when he has five minutes
left
and one minute left oren you're first up
to defend the resolution
you'll have 17 and a half minutes jane
please close the initial vote
and take it away oren all right well
thank you jean and soho forum so much
for for hosting this
uh and and reason foundation as well uh
i enjoy reading what what you guys put
out even if i i
don't necessarily agree with it all the
time uh and
and thank you to scott for for joining
for this for this debate
the last time i debated scott we were in
dallas and it turned out he was from
dallas and he
shouted go cowboys and pumped his fist
and that was sort of the end of the
debate
so i'm grateful we're in cyberspace this
time
uh and and very excited to talk about
industrial policy i think a good
starting point is probably
uh to define industrial policy and and
it's it's a pretty simple concept
in my mind anyway it's it's the idea
that we should have public policy
uh that encourages investment in
particular sectors of the economy
uh that is at the end of the day we we
would like to see investment occurring
in some pattern
other than what uh would happen uh
in the absence of any any policy
involvement at all
and and i'll try to take a fairly
structured approach to laying out the
case for this it seems to me there are
two uh key things that you have to
believe
if uh if if you want to believe that
industrial policy
uh is a good idea and that the united
states should adopt one
uh the first is that we care that is
that
it matters to us where their investment
occurs in the economy
uh and then the second is that we could
do anything about it obviously you could
have a situation where there's a problem
but
either there is no solution or or we
don't think government could
could do anything that would improve
matters but in my view anyway there
there is a problem here and
and while certainly government will not
get everything right uh there there is
an opportunity to do better
than we're doing now so why do we care
why does it matter where investment goes
in the economy
i i guess my argument comes down to uh a
quote attributed i think he actually
said it but we'll have to admit it's
attributed to michael boskin who was the
chair of the council of economic
advisors for george h.w bush
and he said one time in in discussing
uh america's strength but but also its
challenges in
uh in high technology uh computer chips
potato chips
what's the difference and the core of my
argument is
is that there is a difference that it
actually matters to america as a nation
it matters to
uh people at the end of the day and the
health of our economy
uh the extent to which we are doing well
in something like computer chips as as
opposed to something like
potato chips another good example is
christina romer
who was the obama economic advisor uh
and and her quote was consumers value
haircuts
as much as hair dryers and and i don't i
don't doubt that's true
i think it's the case that if all we ask
about is
consumers at this moment in time uh
do they care how much investment is in
one part of the economy or another
obviously
they don't but over time over time if
you think about the trajectory our
economy is on
uh and as producers and workers as well
as consumers as people who
are are hoping that there will be a
healthy economy and robust industries in
their area where they and their
neighbors
can contribute productively find good
work support their families
for all those reasons i think these
things do matter
so why do they matter well first they
matter for
for issues of national security and
resiliency
and and sometimes i almost feel bad
bringing up this this piece of the
puzzle because it is it is such an
obvious case for industrial policy
uh but but it is worth noting that
america cares that it can for instance
produce the things that its defense base
needs and obviously we do that in
in the defense industry we we have very
aggressive policies to ensure that we
can
uh make things like fighter jets
domestically
uh but but as everyone knows and as i
assume scott will be emphasizing
uh supply chains are complicated uh if
you can
design and assemble the jet uh that's
great
but you also need the semiconductors
you also need the steel at the end of
the day you also need a supply of
engineers who
understand aeronautics and so if we want
to have a strong
industrial base we need to make sure our
economy
is one that is in peace time as well as
war time uh
maintaining a strong domestic capacity
and capability in in a whole host of
areas
obviously that's not something that
markets are going to take into account
that's not something that that price
signals are going to ensure
uh and so if we we want it to happen
there is going to have to be a role for
policy
the same goes for resiliency more
generally and and i think the pandemic
that that we've seen this year is a good
illustration of this
uh there are concerns that we might want
to have
in our society beyond just how much we
can buy
on a particular nice day the resilience
of our supply chains
our insulation from foreign actors who
might have a different attitude toward
our well-being
those things matter and we have a
national interest
in ensuring that we can uh protect our
supplies of those kinds of things that
we have resilience rather than fragility
and again that's not something that that
the market is necessarily going to
consider
uh you'll you'll hear me returning to
this point a lot that this is not
something the market takes into account
because it's such an important one you
know i think economists
talk narrowly in terms of market
failures uh and
and certainly as i go through through my
case here i could define each of these
things as a market failure
but ultimately i think it's important to
step back and realize that
that the issue here is a little bit
broader that there simply are some
things that markets and price signals
do and are designed to do and we trust
to do well
and there are some things that that they
don't and
uh thinking about uh what investments
today
are going to be to the benefit of the
nation over the long term
is just not something markets are for it
is not something investors are going to
consider
or incentivize to consider so if if we
think there is anything worthwhile in
trying to consider it
uh we're going to have to do that some
other way so first was national security
and resilience
the second point and in my mind probably
the the central one
is innovation and productivity um it is
it is a problem for uh
the economy that what we can make today
in many ways determines what we can make
tomorrow and that decisions made today
about what a peer
efficient and satisfy consumer needs
have a lot of consequences for the
trajectory that our economy will be on
over time
and there are a few different ways of
looking at this one i really like is
work done by
uh harvard's ricardo houseman and mit
cesar hidalgo
looking at just the the diversity of
capabilities uh
and technologies within an economy and
of course the traditional model
of comparative advantage says the more
you can specialize the better
and and what they find is that actually
at the level of the national economy the
opposite is true
um and this is just i like quoting the
economists right up of them because it's
clearest
the products a country makes today
determines which products they will be
able and likely to make tomorrow
through the evolution of their
capabilities uh so
so we need to think about that
trajectory if we care about what we make
tomorrow a really concrete example of
this
comes from andy grove the the long-time
chairman and ceo
of intel uh who wrote i think a very
important article about a decade ago
talking about what had happened to
investment in innovation and lamenting
in a sense the the death of silicon
valley obviously
silicon valley as a developer of apps is
as robust as ever
but as an actual innovator of of the
kind that is is generating new
knowledge and engineering prowess uh it
really isn't anymore and
and what grove wrote was describing what
had happened in in the semiconductor
industry in particular
our pursuit of our individual businesses
which often involves transferring
manufacturing and a great deal of
engineering out of the country
has hindered our ability to bring
innovations to scale at home
without scaling we don't just lose jobs
we lose our hold on new technologies
losing the ability to scale will
ultimately damage our capacity
to innovate and so again we could
describe this narrowly as a market
failure
that there are spillovers from
manufacturing and engineering to
upstream innovation and research
but we could also just say more
generally that we care about the health
of our
of our industrial ecosystems and the
decisions that individual companies are
going to make about where to locate
production
are not going to take that into account
the reality is that we've we've seen the
the result of america ignoring this we
have seen in recent years arguably
recent decades
uh significant declines in in the rate
of productivity growth
therefore streaming declines in the rate
of economic growth
uh and and while it's more subjective i
would argue quite significant declines
in in the rate of
of engineering and innovation capability
and and that's something that harms us
all both as as workers and consumers
in the long run the the third area and
and the one that i think uh people get
most
uh uh what's a polite way
people get their backs up about this one
is that there's a concern for employment
here
that i think is worth considering uh
going back to that semiconductor potato
you know
the computer chip potato chip example uh
the kinds of jobs created in the
computer chip industry and the kind
created in the in the potato chip
industry may be quite different
uh even more so the kinds of jobs
created in the hair dresser and hair
dryer
industries are going to be different and
one thing that you see
over time and over place is that
uh manufacturing industries and by
manufacturing i don't just mean
the the assembly of things i'm including
resource extraction and
infrastructure related work and and real
work in the physical economy in a sense
uh that that causes things to move
uh turns out to have some really
important properties
one of those properties is is a place
where
men with relatively less education tend
to have a comparative advantage and tend
to earn
relatively higher wages and so if we see
social value
in having those kinds of jobs available
again the market doesn't care
uh a second way that they're important
is that those are actually the place
where we get
a lot of our productivity growth over
time and i think the hairdresser example
is really illustrative here you know at
the end of the day
a barber today is not all that much more
productive than a barber
a hundred years ago uh it still takes a
certain amount of time to cut ahead of
hair
and and generally speaking that's true
for a lot of of the service sector that
that
people otherwise celebrate uh jobs
shifting into
what allows those jobs to be good jobs
with rising wages at the end of the day
is that they are providing services to
people who are themselves
more productive if if there's no
underlying source of
rising productivity it's very hard to
get that out of out of an overly
service-based economy
and especially for low-wage service
workers
so i think making stuff matters in that
respect
i think making stuff also matters
because of where it gets made
an economy that has a more diverse
industrial base in more different
industries with investment flowing to
more different places
is likely to also see a greater
geographic dispersion
of prosperity and that's something our
country is really struggling with as
more and more
investment flows into finance and tech
you know in a more concentrated set
of metropolitan areas uh eig the
economic innovation group has done
excellent work
looking at the concentration of job
creation really since the great
recession and showing the extent to
which
uh essentially all of it has been in the
the top 20 percent of zip codes
and essentially half of it was in just
five metropolitan areas
uh and and and that's a real problem for
uh
the the most people who live somewhere
else uh and
and if we want to have a country that
allows people to uh
live where they want to live and
supports them in their ways of lives and
connection to their families and their
communities
we need to think about the geographic
distribution of economic
activity as well the final point i'll
make about
why we care so much about this uh and
it's
five minutes
is that for local economies to thrive
they have to make something that they
can sell
to the rest of the world and i'm not
even talking about internationally i'm
talking about even nationally
your local community has to make
something that
other people want and it can send to
them in return for the
cars and electronics and medicine and
everything else it wants
and while while manufactured goods are
not the only tradable goods they're
they're certainly the largest category
of them and when you when you erode your
manufacturing base
and you and you celebrate a aggressive
shift into services
you end up with communities doing what i
call exporting need
which means at the end of the day if
they don't have anything to sell
outside of their own community they end
up needing influxes of transfer payments
uh to support them and so for instance
the occupational therapist
serving people on disability becomes
technically the community's exporter
uh he exports to the rest of the country
uh his care of people in disability in
that community
for which government disability payments
flow in
uh and and that's not a good economic
model i i don't think any guests would
say that is
uh now manufacturing obviously has not
collapsed entirely in this country
uh but but it is it it has faced serious
challenges
it's true that we would expect it to
decline as a share of the economy over
time
but the absolute decline in
manufacturing jobs by the millions
over the past couple of decades is not
something we would necessarily expect
it's not something a lot of other
developed economies like germany
switzerland japan
have faced uh and likewise whereas they
see much
higher uh compensation levels in
manufacturing we've seen a total
stalling out
of productivity in fact productivity in
the manufacturing sector has fallen
in five of the last six years for anyone
who thinks that automation is
is is what's really going on uh it's not
so i think we should do something about
this if we can i think there are
important industries that are at the
cutting edge of future development
they're industries that are important to
the health of a diverse economy
that are not receiving the kind of
investment that they need
and that we could do something to help
guide investment toward
now what would that look like uh the the
first caveat i'll give is obviously it
wouldn't be perfect i'm not here to say
there's some perfect
flawless industrial policy the question
is whether we could do something better
than
the status quo uh and and there i think
we could
uh now what we shouldn't do we shouldn't
do venture we shouldn't have the
government playing the role of venture
capitalist
uh we should we're not i'm not talking
about having the government decide how
many screws each factory should make
uh but there are some things that i
think would work and and there are some
things that we've seen work
over time and over place uh it is in
fact the american tradition to do this
you know adam
adam smith in the very paragraph where
he introduces the invisible hand
uh talks about the focus on domestic
industry
as as the type of investment that is
going to be happening
alexander hamilton obviously who's in
many ways seen as the father of the
modern industrial economy was a strong
advocate
of industrial policy and the american
system which dominated
uh economic policy in in the first
century of the republic
uh was essentially an industrial policy
even reagan had aggressive industrial
policy in semiconductors on cars
the reason that the japanese moved a
significant share of auto manufacturing
to the american south was because we had
affirmative government policy that
recognized that that would be a good
thing
so what kind of things do i think we
should do i'll give four ideas and we
can talk more about these as we go
along uh one is the concept of
pre-competitive consortia
which is the idea that the the various
companies within an industry
essentially joined together to create a
research center and they put up their
own money
and then the government matches what
they've put it so when
you have one minute ago so we we test
for it being a good idea because we make
them put their money where their mouth
is but we support it as well
and whatever innovation comes out of it
uh everyone in the industry can share a
second is education and recognizing that
our support for education should be
focused in the kinds of degrees that
support
industry and we should not be shy about
putting more support into
engineering degrees than dance degrees a
third is what i'd call local content
requirements which means for really
important supply chains in say
advanced communications equipment
semiconductors actually requiring that
the supply chains
uh source a certain element of their
components domestically creating the
demand
for more domestic supply and then
finally
i think we need to think about trade
balances and recognize that a big piece
of what's happened is that
demand that could have been fulfilled by
domestic producers is instead
build elsewhere and instead we ship our
assets overseas
and i think discouraging the foreign
acquisition of assets so that it's
relatively more attractive to buy from
american producers
would benefit our economy in the long
run so thank you very much and and
looking forward to hearing scott uh
thank you oren uh just 13 seconds over
so what i'm a very minor misdemeanor uh
scott you're going to get an extra 13
seconds
and out of uh over and above your 17 and
a half minutes
uh scott speaking for the negative take
it away scott
um well uh thank you oren and gene um
great to be here um if even if it is
only virtually and um
got to say great timing um i actually
have a new paper on manufacturing
industrial policy and national security
coming out in a couple weeks
so this is excellent marketing for that
um
and i hope everybody will will click
that link in the future
um now look i'd like to spend my time uh
probing some questions that the debate
resolution we have here
um to promote prosperity among all
income groups the us government should
adopt an industrial policy
um and and that most discussions of
industrial policy raise so
my hope is that in asking these
questions we're really going to
crystallize the issues at play
and make for a more productive
discussion instead of y'all just
watching lauren and me
talk past each other for another hour um
now since it's my time
i'm also going to try to answer these
questions or at least offer some
possible answers and in the process show
why i think the resolution here today
and industrial policy more generally
should should be rejected
so with that let's let's get started so
first i mean i think it's imperative
to first ask um what are the problems
that exist
right now in america that could possibly
be solved
by industrial policy and or enhance it
some of this but i really want to get
into the weeds about
what these problems are and and you know
since this debate's about industrial
policy i think we should start with
manufacturing so
first is the manufacturing sector really
in need of saving
we hear this a lot from guys like marco
rubio president trump bernie sanders
elizabeth warren and the rest
that we've had massive
de-industrialization that requires a
total rethink of economic policy
but is that really true well yes as oren
mentioned we've lost manufacturing jobs
in in the early 2000s although we've
gained about a million
since um and the u.s the sector's share
of the economy has declined but
but is that an issue well it turns out
there are problems with these supposed
problems
um in particular both declining
manufacturing sector jobs and the
declining share of gdp
primarily reflect long-term global
trends that are disconnected from
specific economic policies whether these
policies
are free market or interventionist so in
terms of
jobs for example the long-term decline
in u.s manufacturing jobs actually
coincided with
rising sector output we'll get to more
on that in a sec
and was mirrored in developing developed
countries around the world
including economies more centered on
manufacturing those with
long-standing trade surpluses and goods
or with more aggressive and more
comprehensive industrial policies
and in fact the us actually lost a
smaller share of manufacturing
deck jobs over the last few decades than
countries like japan
and germany and i can get in the weeds
of those studies if you want but
the fact is that there's very little to
indicate that altering a trade balance
or implementing
uh industrial policy will change
the trajectory the overall trajectory of
u.s manufacturing jobs
um particularly as a share of the
workforce in terms of gdp
share our share of the economy this the
story is really similar manufacturing's
declining share of total u.s gdp
reflects
broad secular trends that are largely
disconnected from government policy and
thus can't be fixed by them
for starters the change in the
industrial sector's gdp
reflects relative strength of services
not the actual weakness of manufacturing
we actually uh it's simply that the
service sector expanded
more quickly than the manufacturing
sector which actually also
expanded too and second the relative
growth of services manufacturing again
reflects fundamental shifts not in
trade balances or industrial policy but
in consumption patterns
in the united states and other countries
away from goods and towards services
so for example u.s consumers back in the
1960s allocated
about half of their annual budgets to
goods but by
by 2010 it was only 33 and these
relative consumption trends coincided
with the manufacturing sector's
declining share of utis u.s gdp
trends that economists have found to be
really strongly linked and which again
are mirrored in countries all over the
world again those with strong industrial
policies like germany or south korea
it turns out this is just a standard
story of economic development
we all buy relatively fewer goods and
more services as we get richer
so it's not something a problem that
demands industrial policy or could be
fixed by it
indeed we're actually seeing this right
now the onset of covet 19 in the united
states actually
uh should reinforce the link between
consumer
sector consumer spending and
manufacturing sector performance
manufacturers in the united states are
actually booming right now
and why because we're all uh trapped in
our houses buying goods instead of
services
and so uh the the sector's
relative growth has really only occurred
because americans can't
buy the services that we typically do
now
meanwhile other measures of u.s
industrial performance
show a sector that is healthy productive
and in many areas thriving
indeed as i show on my paper the u.s
manufacturing sector actually
remains among the most productive in the
world and has expanded in real
inflation-adjusted terms since the 1990s
continuing earlier trends in output
investment and profitability
one of my colleagues at cato documented
back in 2007.
uh for example not to get too much in
the weeds uh the united states ranked
second in the world in 2018
before the trade wars began uh in total
manufacturing value added at 2.3
trillion dollars
second in the world of merchandise
exports uh our manufacturing center's
performance was stronger on a per worker
that basis
in terms of productivity far
outperforming china japan
south korea and other top manufacturing
countries
in terms of investment the united states
is the top
recipient of manufacturing foreign
direct investment
in the oecd more than doubling the
second place nation
nation in fact in 2018
total fdi inflows into the u.s
manufacturing sector at about 167
billion
were larger than total fdi inflows into
china for the same year
at only 138 billion inward fdi stocks
during that year
hit 1.77 trillion
this is not a sector that is dying or in
which people do not want to invest
historical data on the sector also show
it to be diverse and growing overall
real manufacturing value added and gross
up output rope
significantly over the last two plus
decades as were investment
capital expenders expenditures r d and
foreign direct investment
financial performance revenues post tax
in income
to post tax income and assets indeed
manufacturing r d
and capex each hit around 260 billion
dollars
before the trade wars began meanwhile
u.s durable goods production where the
best paying jobs are
has been particularly impressive since
the 90s posting gains in real value
added real gross output
of 109 and 36 since 97
and contrary to some claims this is not
merely about computing power even if you
remove those sectors
you see substantial gains in durable
goods output over the last
two uh two decades
and based on these another two uh these
other data we talk about national
security the last two defense department
reports on
the defense industrial base and its
production capabilities
concluded that it is profitable and
expanding overall
now that said look the top-line bad data
do certainly hide significant changes in
the sector over the past two decades
in response to various economic forces
it's not some big monolith
some industries expanded particularly in
things like aerospace
transportation metals metal metals
computers
medical equipment and so on but some
industries particularly non-durable
goods
and low labor-intensive
goods like textiles tobacco have
contracted since the 90s in response to
either globalization or changing
consumer tastes
but however the changes in these
non-durables have been offset
by gains in other more advanced more
advanced and capital-intensive
non-durable industries like
pharmaceuticals or energy
and overall data on the sector
performance shows a
flexible dynamic and healthy sector
that's responsible to market forces
and this is a flexibility that can
actually prove quite critical
in times of unexpected national urgency
and in fact
again recent experience bears this out a
new report from the international trade
commission examined trade and domestic
production of essential medical goods
during the pandemic
and found that manufacturers responded
quickly to boost supplies or make new
products
in other words the market responded and
it worked pretty well
surely not everything was perfect demand
was absolutely insane and there were
massive shocks to both domestic and
import supply
but overall our supply chains proved
pretty resilient
a testament to not only the hard work
and engineering ingenuity of us
retailers and manufacturers
but also the united states economic
dynamism and our industrial capabilities
more broadly
now orrin mentioned national security so
i'll just mention again
that the manufacturing sectors that are
most closely associated with national
security
have not been declining uh this includes
not just defense uh sectors like
aerospace or tanks or missiles or
munitions
but it also includes things like medical
uh excuse me like metals and
semiconductors
and motor vehicles energy chemicals and
the rest
certainly some output falls and some
output rises over time
but the overall picture is one of
stability and health
not decline but okay so what about
manufacturing jobs maybe these are
something really special to target
well it's already discussed it's
questionable to assume that certain key
trends in manufacturing
could have been reversed via industrial
policy the changes in manufacturing jobs
alone really provide little insight into
the state of american
manufacturing of the need for industrial
policy
but look u.s policy might be able to in
theory produce
a one-time increase in manufacturing
employment is that really though
worth doing well is american prosperity
in other words
broadly defined really dependent on
adding say a couple million
manufacturing jobs and a pre-pandemic
workforce of 165 million people
well probably not as my
cato colleague ryan bourne documented
last year
there's really little to indicate that
u.s manufacturing jobs
are so particularly special as to
warrant even more direct and specific
government support
first they're not significantly more
secure especially for low-skilled
manufacturing workers whose jobs have
been disappearing for decades and are
most exposed to automation and trade
there there for example it took back
in 1980 about 10 man hours to produce a
ton of steel today it takes about
two um the newest steel plants just
produced
needed 14 employees to make 500
000 tons of steel unless demand for
steel is unlimited and it is not
this is not a good jobs program
of course we could try to slow down
productivity or reshore monotonous and
low-skilled manufacturing activities but
the economic implications of doing that
lower wages and higher prices can't
possibly be considered prosperity
second u.s manufacturing jobs tend to be
highly productive that's true
and due in part to the aforementioned r
d but this productivity again
caps employment because the higher
productivity means you need fewer
workers to produce widgets or whatever
you're making
and it beggars belief that more
government intervention will make the
industry industries
leaner and meaner in fact it would
probably be to
do the opposite okay well maybe boosting
nominal manufacturing employment would
solve
labor force participation well probably
not again
the labor force participation rate hit
about 63 and a half percent before the
pandemic
and that's right where it was in 1979
when manufacturing jobs were an all-time
high
so again there's little to think that
targeting manufacturing jobs is going to
fix that problem
other data suggests that labor force
participation problems but
are really not about a worsening job
market in manufacturing but really about
reduced patterns
of job seeking in other words research
shows that
most prime edge men not in the labor
force report that they're disabled
five minutes five minutes to go going
yeah yeah sorry what's that
five minutes to go yeah that they're
disabled or not in the labor force so
that probably won't work either
now leaving aside what's driving those
trends what's to think that industrial
policy is going to fix them
in fact there's a lot of evidence that
shows
that even in the hottest mark job market
in a generation
there were tons of job openings and
manufacturers were having
problems filling them so finally that
brings us to wages and benefits and once
again manufacturing jobs reveal little
specialness to warrant
some grand industrial policy i mean for
starters contrary to conventional wisdom
incomes and wages have not been stagnant
over the last few decades
uh in fact median production supervisory
wages are up about 30 percent since the
early 1990s
um wage in total compensation up 61
and and the wage stagnation that did
occur happened long before things like
globalization or deaths of despair took
off
or male marriage prospects declined in
the rest so the connection between
manufacturing these trends is pretty
weak
um so uh our the idea that there is a
large manufacturing wage premium it
turns out
that median base pay for manufacturing
is still pretty good
but these days there's actually better
pay found outside the manufacturing
sector
in fact there are a lot of manufacturing
jobs that have lower pay
than the average job in the services
sector and so forth
now if you actually look at some of
these
professions these are not just simply in
soft skills job there are a lot of manly
blue collar jobs out there
paying quite well whether it's logging
or wholesale trade or construction or
transportation and warehousing and
utilities
wage growth has also been faster in
these areas and unlike manufacturing
most were expected to grow in the future
this is all quite good ex and and thus
indicates that there's no special
benefit to having more manufacturing
jobs
now my favorite reason example of this
is warehouse jobs which have
unsuccessful
unsurprisingly exploded this year um and
during the e-commerce era we've seen
substantial wage increases and jobs that
now pay
quite a serious premium a significant
premium over blue collar manufacturing
jobs
and finally it's essential to ask is to
note the united states has been
trying to increase manufacturing jobs
for decades with little avail
as the congressional research service
put it a few years ago
although congress has established a wide
variety of tax preferences direct
subsidies import restraints and other
federal programs
with a goal of retain or recapturing
manufacturing jobs only a small
proportion of workers
is now employed in factories so
maybe maybe we we still you know what
about prosperity i think more broadly
well
there's a lot of in evidence to indicate
that prosperity
in terms of consumption i know oren
doesn't think that matters pretty much
but
that's going really really well uh the
share of american households with
telephones electricity automobiles
stoves refrigerators and the rest is
approaching 100
the gains for below medium income
families are particularly
impressive you also see that
the time we need to work to get these
things has also improved
the amount average amount of time that
an unskilled worker needs
to buy a long list of everyday items has
declined by about 72
since the 60s so we're working less and
getting more for our money that's
great now i want to move on to the next
question
so what do we mean even by industrial
policy now oren has listed some examples
and i think that's great
because sometimes
industrial policy is couch disease broad
macro economic programs but i think it's
good that oren has talked about things
like boosting semiconductors
or how many did you go one minute ago
and here i think the record is really
clear whether it's semiconductor
production
or machine tools or
uh steel tariffs or the jones act
i can go on and on and on the results of
these
industrial policies are not not good uh
it turns out
that we have been doing this for decades
and it really beggars belief that we're
going to be able to do a really good
job of doing it in the future simply
because we have
better planners more altruistic people
in charge
i think the the other thing to note here
is that um
there's a lot of evidence that we don't
need the industrial policies in the
first place now oren mentioned
consortiums
there's actually good evidence for
example that past semiconductor
consortiums by the government
actually weren't needed and did not
achieve anything near to what the
private market
could have done and there's examples as
well
that that for example arpa-e
funding hasn't actually improved
clean tech startups as compared to what
again the private market
can do scott you've you've you've
exceeded your extra time a little bit so
now
i'll leave it to the report let's defer
yeah okay thank you thank you scott
uh and now uh we get to the uh rebuttal
portion
five minute minutes apiece for this or
i'm gonna give you an extra an extra
eight seconds because scott went over
so oren take it away with your five
minute rebuttal
great i i'm going to start with
something a little bit
uh in the weeds but i think it's
important that we be talking from the
same data
as we have this debate uh and and
frankly i i disagree pretty strongly
with
with the picture that that scott just
presented so let me just
just kind of run through uh some of the
data points and explain my perspective
on them
so you know the first is that scott
emphasized that that output
in the manufacturing sector uh is up
uh it's it's in total up very very
slightly but has essentially been flat
for two decades and there's a very
strange accounting quirk
in the way we account for the number of
transistors in semiconductors
that accounts for essentially all of it
if you look at our manufacturing sector
excluding the electronics and
semiconductors segment
manufacturing output has actually been
declining for the last two decades
and i think it's important to ask
compared to what because of course what
we should expect in in a in a healthy
growing economy
uh would be would be a significant
increase so so that in in absolute terms
if not as a percentage of gdp and so the
fact that that actually our
manufacturing
sector has failed to grow now for two
decades i think is certainly
a problem uh i think if we talk about
manufacturing productivity you know
scott mentioned a bunch of
of countries that are as productive or
that we are as productive as
uh he skipped europe though uh and the
reality is that the productivity of the
manufacturing sector
uh or certainly the the wages earned by
workers in the us manufacturing sector
is far far below
uh what you see in in a country like uh
you know germany or switzerland the the
most recent bls data i have is from
uh 2012 but at that point the the hourly
cost of a u.s manufacturing worker
was 35-67 as compared to 45-79
in germany and 57.79 in switzerland so
there's
there's an extraordinary gap there
the the third point i would make is that
scott mentioned foreign direct
investment and the idea that that all of
this investment is flowing into u.s
manufacturing
it's important to understand that
foreign direct investment is almost
entirely just
foreign companies buying u.s companies
and u.s
assets it's not actually a greenfield
investment
in fact of more than 200 billion dollars
in foreign direct investment last year
only four billion uh was actually
the investment in creation of any new
capacity
and i believe about one billion of that
was in manufacturing
so it's not actually an area attracting
new investment
of that kind uh and then finally i think
it's very important when we think about
labor force participation
uh to keep in mind that again we're
talking about labor force participation
for particular groups
and if you look at labor force
participation in particular for men
without college degrees
um that's that's where you see a
significant decline and
essentially what you see is a pattern
where in each recession we see a
significant dip
uh and then there's no subsequent
rebound and so they're sort of
like a series of downward steps uh that
that has left the
the those share of men uh in the labor
force
significantly lower uh so i i think when
you put all those things together what
what you see
is a manufacturing sector that that is
no by no means dying i i don't think i
suggested that
but but is not performing uh as well as
some of our pure economies uh and and
it's certainly not performing as well
as it could be as i mentioned also
productivity growth
has been declining for five of the past
six years
uh so so in my mind the question is not
uh is manufacturing gone
obviously it's not it's not did some
particular set of public policies
destroy manufacturing obviously they
didn't
uh it's whether public policy could
improve upon what we have
and so that's where we have a question
well do we think more investment
into this sector would be constructive
uh and
and i think there there there's an
obvious case that it would be
um the the last piece i want to add to
the data conversation that i think is
really telling
is you know scott described this shift
in conclusion one minute ago
to services um but of course that's in
relative terms in absolute terms the
amount of manufactured stuff we consume
continues to grow
and the way you can tell is because we
have a skyrocketing trade deficit in
goods
we continue to buy more and more goods
they're just not being made here they're
being made somewhere else
i think especially troubling to to the
point about innovation is if you look in
at the balance in advanced technology
products we track that separately in
2000 we actually ran a slight surplus
in the production and export of advanced
technology products
and by 2019 we were running a 133
billion dollar deficit
so that's the sort of trend that i look
at and say um
there's certainly no reason that needs
to be the case uh and we should ask if
policy can do something about it
now as scott didn't really get into any
of the policies
i i suggested i'd love to get his
reaction to those
uh and and then maybe we can talk more
about uh whether
whether or not they'd be likely to to do
good uh but but to summarize output is
flat to down
in manufacturing productivity in the u.s
manufacturing sector
is much worse than europe that fdi in
new capacity
is virtually zero labor force
participation
for young men is far in serious decline
and we see a significant demand for more
manufactured goods in the us
uh it's simply not being produced here
thank you lauren
uh scott uh a little over five minutes
for you
to uh give you a rebuttal take it away
so so i
i first just to say um trade deficit and
goods
um has only skyrocketed in nominal terms
as a percentage of gdp
it's actually been flat since the 1980s
uh meaning that we aren't actually again
consuming more goods as overall um but
i don't want to get into a data fight i
think that again oren has raised the
right question
can real legitimate u.s industrial
policy
improve where we are today and again i
think that's where history of u.s
industrial policy is really quite clear
now i go through a lot of this in my
paper but but i'll just give you a
couple examples again let's talk
semiconductors well the last time we
tried to boost semiconductor output
in the 1980s it was a debacle
the united states semiconductor trade
agreement with japan
which regulated drams was plagued
by uh a a
high cost for american computer
companies
it was plagued by picking the wrong
products
it turns out that people were exiting
the market for chips that
that they targeted and they were
entering other pro
other markets for other types of chips
in fact things got so bad
that there were reports of japanese
firms which were forced to buy
american semiconductors just dumping
them
in the tokyo bay that is not a good use
of productive resources and again the
research and development consortium
simatec which has been praised
occasionally was found to
not only be captured by certain domestic
interests and certain chip producers
actually harming other smaller chip
makers but really didn't actually
produce
anything much of value particularly that
could not be produced by the private
sector
well why didn't this work and this is
just a classic
example of why industrial policy in the
united states has been
just so unsuccessful first the planners
picked the wrong
products to subsidize it's a classic
case of the knowledge problem
second there was politics uh drams were
the focus because that's where the
lobbying energy
was seema tech had these producers
because that's again the established
companies that lobbied for them
so this is public choice in action
now this exact thing could be happening
again with new u.s subsidies but we'll
talk about that another time
or we can talk about trump's steel
tariffs unfortunately i have a lot of
personal experience
with this and here you had a u.s steel
industry that had captured the
department of commerce and had
uh former colleagues in the trump
administration
uh providing a tariff protection for an
industry that not only had received
billions in subsidies and tons of
tariffs before but did not need it at
all that had at a 70
market share things were so ridiculous
in that case that defense secretary
mattis said at the time hey we don't
need tariffs at all we don't need these
national security protection
we only need about three percent of
steel production and it turns out that
again
um the the his advice was totally
ignored so time and time again i can't
go through all the examples of the jones
act for example
trump area subsidies to carrier and
foxconn
ethanol mandates machine tools
restrictions uh
textile and apparel production subsidies
japanese
automobile quotas anti-dumping duties
and so forth time and time again they
run into the same problems
high costs failed objectives so
and and that gets i think to the other
point we have a
ton of experience with this stuff and it
keeps showing
massive amounts of unintended
consequences whether it's
uh you know the fact that past
industrial policy for
semiconductors and machine tools
actually boosted new competitors in
korea or china
we have costs and hidden costs um and
that's even
admitted by supporters of industrial
policy for example at brookings and
elsewhere
and that doesn't even that's just direct
costs it doesn't look at the opportunity
cost it doesn't look at the
political cost it doesn't look at the
male investment
and getting speaking of that there's uh
substantial misallocation of resources
so our subsidies
one minute one minute yeah push
resources to the wrong places
so instead of for example uh in
providing billions or hundreds of
millions of dollars in loans
to uh viable companies that produce
pharmaceutical inputs
we end up subsidizing kodak like we did
last year
a former camera company that turned into
a just
absolute mess and that again caused
capital to flow away
from what it could have been productive
manufacturing enterprises
and there's distortions upon distortions
there's dispressed economic activity
that arises from all these types of
economic nationalism
including local content uh measures
which by the way
are banned by world trade organization
rules and that gets to another
problem we have there's potential trade
disputes that arise
and that creates not only uncertainty
and potential uh trade conflict but also
can present
uh potential duties and tariffs on u.s
exports that also goes for targeted
subsidies
that are also disciplined by these
global trade rules
now of course there are high prices and
that also includes
for american manufacturers due to the
globalized nature of the sector when you
put tariffs on steel and aluminum you
end up actually depressing outfit in the
automotive sector
um yeah tons of economic evidence yeah
your time's up uh
scott uh we're going to the q a portion
of the evening
you both have we'll have the opportunity
to ask each other
a question or two or three questions
right now
or later on we can give it to audience
questions
uh oren uh would you like to put a
question just guide at this point
uh sure i guess just one to start with
i think you know he gave good examples
of things that
were not my proposals that uh didn't
work and i would agree with many of them
uh but it seems to me that a lot does
work and i would just
be curious to get his reaction to this
observation
uh from economist david goldman which is
that every important technology of the
digital digital age began as a no
with a darpa or nasa subsidy the
semiconductor cmos manufacturing of
semi-detectors the graphical user
interface
semiconductor lasers optical networks
led plasma displays
and the internet itself uh and and i'm
curious if
if if in scott's view either those
programs are better than the ones he's
condemning
uh or if he believes we would have made
more progress faster
on all of those things if government had
just gotten out of the way
scott yeah so um
i think the the general answer is
is precisely what i was saying in the in
the first part and that is that
um these these policies exist
they don't exist in a vacuum and so when
you say ah government policy created x y
or z
well the reality is that we don't know
what would have happened in the absence
of of those programs we also know
that that there are there's a lot of
evidence out there
that precisely these types of programs
do
not achieve better outcomes
than what are achieved in the absence of
the programs and by
private market now look that's not to
say that there's no market failures out
there or that there's no
uh role for government at all but what
it's saying is that when you get into
the weeds of specific u.s industrial
policies of the type
the s that oren has proposed whether
it's local content
restrictions and buy american rules or
whether it's r d
consortium like cimatec um the the
the results there are not very good and
oh by the way they
also tend to run into and morph into
things that are worse things like the
jones act or the semiconductor trade
agreement
it is not the fact that these things can
just exist in a vacuum
so overall yes i think that the
government and government policy can
achieve
certain outcomes i think that basic
funding for r
d or whatever is is is different
from very much from industrial policy
and what i mean industrial policy is
specific
picking specific winners and losers in
the market
to achieve specific industrial outcomes
and that i think is where there is tons
of history and unfortunately
two decades of my life as a trade lawyer
in the weeds of the anti-dumping program
and the steel tariff exclusion program
that shows that these things tend to
induce uh produce
massive distortions and costs
thank you uh scott scott do you have a
question you would like to put to warren
yeah i i do i so uh or in your book
you and related writings you you've
appeared to be half
supportive of the foxconn deal in
wisconsin
um and and so which we i think everybody
can agree has has been
kind of a total debacle could you
clarify what that deal was
right so wisconsin gave billions of
dollars
to uh a taiwan producer foxconn
to create an lcd factory there and the
whole thing has been
really plagued and the idea was to
create a bunch
of high-tech manufacturing jobs right
precisely the type of stuff
that oren said earlier that we want
right that we the
nation needs now foxconn of course this
this deal has has proven to be an
absolute mess um not only in terms of
the high cost but in terms of all sorts
of distortions and
uh the thing basically the whole thing
has fallen through
so i just want to know i mean are you
supportive of that or not or
i guess the better way to put it is if
you could choose between
a foxconn style deal which is what we
get a lot
or nothing which would it be
lauren well so i'm sorry i was just
i'm i'm i'm not sure where i've ever
said anything supportive of the foxconn
deal in
in my book what i wrote about i i'm just
quoting wisconsin's approach is half
right
paying for jobs makes sense how they've
gone about it however does
not right and and so i i
believe i've always said that i i
thought the foxconn approach was
was a mistake and and as i said in the
caveats to the policies i was proposing
i think you know playing venture capital
list or trying to allocate
to specific firms is a mistake um so
i i'm not sure why you say i've been
happier
i'm sorry i said half supported that
exactly that point that that look the
idea of
government subsidizing jobs is good but
they just should do it differently well
my
my question though is let's say you
don't have the choice right that that
look no no
policy given that you know unfortunately
it's not you
in charge of either the government of
wisconsin or
or sitting in congress um let's say
that's the only thing out there
is is that something worth doing so
i i just clarify i'm not half supportive
of foxconn
the chapter was about wage subsidies and
i was giving a wage subsidy as an
example of something that is a good idea
and giving money to foxconn is something
that is bad so
i i'm again not at all supportive of
foxconn
long before it became a complete
disaster uh to your question if my only
choices are
nothing or foxconn uh then then my
choice
i would vote for nothing but i i don't
understand
why those are my choices any more than
if i asked you if
you know my industrial policy or
becoming communist china were the only
two choices
no which would you prefer i mean
fortunately there are other options out
there
and uh and and i think that's what uh
what we should be focused on okay
uh uh at this point uh do you want to
give it to audience questions or in the
scott and uh
wave your own questions for the moment
yeah okay um
well uh we're getting questions
focused at warren i guess
one of the related questions would be
can you oren cite a country
that has had a beneficial industrial
policy and then
questionnaires latch upon the classic
case of japan
the mitti in japan where
research has apparently shown that mitti
chose
the stagnant industries there was a lot
of political corruption
and then when japan was riding high as
the big planning
economy that's when uh when when
stagnation
uh set in when it's uh when it's lost
decade
ensued so japan was supposed to be the
best example of industrial policy and it
turned out to be one of the worst
could you address some of those
statements uh uh in any way you want
yeah i wouldn't have cited japan as the
best example i think japan
um in in the structure of its society
and economy is is uniquely sclerotic in
in in ways that have done it a great
disservice
um you know the examples i would point
to in east asia
are are taiwan south korea and singapore
um all of which have have pursued
industrial policy and essentially
chosen industries in which they wanted
to win i mean there's no reason that
taiwan has a natural comparative
advantage in semiconductors uh
nor that korea does or korea in
shipbuilding
uh but uh through government-led policy
they uh they built uh
or supported the development of very
successful industries
i think elsewhere in the world uh you
know in europe i think germany is
probably the best example of a company
of excuse me a country that has a range
of policies designed to support its
manufacturing sector
uh in terms of education in terms of
what it calls its its manufacturing
institutes
which have a very long german name that
i won't try to pronounce
uh that that essentially are public
partner private ships
partnerships to to commercialize
technology into the manufacturing sector
uh i think israel is a very interesting
example of a country that has uh focused
intensively on on defense and i.t
and obviously become a world leader in
both uh
and and so those are those are some of
the examples i would point to
israel germany taiwan singapore
korea could you comment on
that scott on
on their successes and their failures
well owen
has made the statement that he does
believe that those five
israel germany taiwan singapore korea
are good
examples role models for the u.s to
pursue
its own industrial policy that those
five have pursued successful industrial
policies
um could you comment on what i believe
was oren's claim
sure um so i i think there's really just
a couple
responses um first is
that uh you know i've always skeptical
of cross-country comparisons
with for the the sheer fact that we are
not those countries
um and again to go back to the united
states experience with industrial policy
just
simply isn't uh isn't very good
and and thus it really i think there's a
reason to be skeptical
but i think the other thing that we need
to consider
is is whether these these
uh countries and whether their approach
actually has been successful for the
economy overall
for example just to give you an example
there is a
a really disproportionate amount of
investment
in south korea and taiwan just for
computer and electronics so these are
are highly specialized
nations in one area now now look maybe
that's good
or maybe it's better to have a more
diverse more stable
economy like united states that's more
dynamic and more responsive
so for example um we we still do
have for example a large semiconductor
industry we actually do
produce a lot of high cutting ed high
tech cutting edge semiconductors
but we also have pharmaceuticals and we
have
uh aerospace and transportation and the
rest
and if you if you i think that is is a
much
better uh approach than trying to kind
of
force uh certain sectors in certain
industries
um and creating kind of a less
diversified economy
thank you uh scott uh a question
another question for you or and i guess
related to that same point with respect
to the
u.s history you have uh
the question to point out acknowledges
that you have said that
government uh subsidy of computers
chips the internet that was successful
uh industrial policy can you cite any
other broad
categories of u.s initiatives
that you would regard as good precedent
that they could build on uh for a
successful
besides besides the entire digital age
um
sure i can keep going i mean look i
think one thing i i would just add
specifically on the digital age
technologies is that while some was was
kind of basic research
in darpa and so forth a huge piece of
the puzzle was
was the huge public-private partnerships
between
uh government academia and and places
like you know bell labs and ibm
uh all the way through the the sort of
uh applied research and
commercialization of the technology
so i think that was a much more
broad-based effort than the sort of you
know
darpa grant piece of it um i think
another fascinating example is
healthcare
um and and i think you know if you look
at what's now happened with
uh with with the vaccine program i don't
want to get into a
debate over what was or wasn't to be
learned from operation warp speed i'm
sure
scott and i could go five hours on just
that um
but i'm more interested in backing up a
stack and noting that
you know we had the uh technology and
capacity and infrastructure to do
something like undertake the development
of a vaccine
uh and with that speed because of the
investment
particularly in the us but but certainly
in other countries as well we've seen
the role of the uk and germany and so
forth
in investing in in the biotech sector i
mean what the us does
through the national institutes of
health through its support of
universities and medical schools
and then through creating the latent
demand
through public health programs health
care programs
uh is is a huge piece of why we have the
amount of investment and progress
in the health care sector that we do and
i think downstream in
in the consumer market uh there are
obviously a lot of problems with
uh with the role the government plays in
healthcare uh but upstream in the in
the innovation stage i think it's it's
an indispensable component
uh of of what has made the u.s
successful
scott you want to comment on uh yeah i i
think the vaccines point is is
awesome and i i like to i think it's a
really excellent example
of why so much of kind of the successes
of industrial policy
are are a bit uh misguided or misleading
i think because
so here you have a perfect example of
really the government staying out of the
way of
vaccine production vaccine innovation
in terms of the bioentech pfizer
approach
you can look at modern and say look
moderna was with the national institute
of health
madeira was involved kind of with the
government a lot on the other hand you
have biointec
a german company which got together with
its research on mrna
it got together with pfizer a american
company
and they really did all of this
themselves outside of operation warp
speed
then they used pfizer's existing
production
networks in the united states and
elsewhere they used a
global supply chain of uh inputs
and workers uh immigrants from all over
the world and the rest
and this was far this was not planned by
the government
now was there support along the way
whether it's in patents or whatever
that's that's fine but the fact is that
this vaccine was
very much an effort of that that existed
privately but
if it hadn't existed we could have
looked at the modern approach and then
aha we
definitely needed government for this
but again because we have the bio and
tech fisa
alternative we can see the private
sector doing it and doing it quite well
and doing it actually a little bit
faster
do you want to respond in any way or
into that uh comment or
wave yeah i mean i you know i think
obviously the the massive purchase
commitment
was was a factor in in in the investment
um of of the pfizer vaccine as well
as i said i i think the details of the
um you know warp speed project itself we
we would we could fight about for days
what what i'm
more struck by though is is the broader
point about trajectory
and that the idea that we wanted to have
an innovative
healthcare sector and the capacity to
develop these things
and the research going on at nih and the
work being done on mmrni
on mrna to begin with um
you know all of these things um are
are not things the private sector was
ever going to do itself because there
were no price signals
for them because that's not what markets
and price signals are for and so i agree
entirely with scott's point
about the incredibly important role in
of the private sector and all of this
and that's why i've tried to take pains
to
emphasize every point here that this is
not a proposal for a central planning
approach that says
government can simply uh soup to nuts
generate things for the
you know in the economy better than the
private sector could
it's an effort to point out that there
are certain things that markets don't do
on their own
uh that i think government policy can
play a role
in and has proved its ability to play a
role in
across countries across sectors uh and
we have a situation in the u.s where
there's a constructive role it could
play
uh in a sector that that has really
lagged and is really suffering
ultimately
uh you know by the competition from
manufacturing sectors elsewhere that do
get this kind of support
another question for you oren
uh picking up on the laundry list of
failures that uh that were
initiated by scott others are adding the
subsidy of solyndra which went bankrupt
the bailout of
general motors that that it seems as
though
as it's been put by some in the audience
that you have a mixture of sort of
corruption and incompetence
incompetence because the people in
charge are not investing their own money
they're investing somebody else's money
uh the
corruption because the uh the people
uh in in in charge are are listening
to the to the corporations that dominate
the economy already
and that could be a prescription for
stagnation is there anything
that you could offer the audience uh to
to assure them that the combination of
incompetence and corruption
that that seems to pervade government
initiatives industrial
planning that that combination can
somehow be
suppressed well look i think the
the the sort of case study approach to
finding every failure along the way is
is an incredibly foolish one um
i would be the first person to say a
significant share
of of the investments that get made are
not going to work
which by the way happens to be true in
the private sector as well i mean if i
were to go pull up
you know the track record of any venture
capital firm and start reading off the
stupidest things they'd invest in
uh that would obviously not be a case
against venture capital
um i think the solyndra example that
being said is not the model i would
support because i
i do think there's a much higher uh
degree
of incompetence and corruption when you
have government bureaucrats trying to
pick the specific companies to
essentially buy equity in
um though i would note that that tesla
is is is something of a counter example
to the solyndra case at this point
um but but the model that i find very
attractive is one that forces
the private sector to put its money
where its mouth is and so to just
elaborate briefly on
on this sort of pre-competitive
consortia concept
what i think is really interesting about
it is
industry has to go first so you know
scott's been saying that cemetec didn't
accomplish anything and so forth
um but the reality is that all the
semiconductor companies put one percent
of their revenue into it
and continue doing it uh and and it
continues to exist today
apparently the the market has decided uh
that there is something valuable here
and so the model that i find appealing
is to say
uh look if an industry group wants to
get together and say we think that this
kind of
uh joint upstream research would have
value to our industry and we are willing
to put money into
it uh then i'd like to see government
matching that
uh and and so that form of subsidy you
know yes absolutely it's a subsidy
uh but it is a subsidy to fund an
activity that has
put public benefits far beyond what the
private players
would capture themselves and so that's
exactly where you would actually
have to define a subsidy as efficient
it's a situation where
uh where the bureaucrat has relatively
less
influence on who gets the money
and it's a situation where you have an
actual market check on whether money's
going to things worth investing in
and would some of those fail absolutely
but
if even a small share of them succeed
uh that ultimately is a huge net benefit
for us
just as a huge share of you know all of
the investments made through
through the digital age probably didn't
succeed
but the net gains of all the incredible
breakthroughs we did have are are the
reason that we do it
and that's something that uh that we
understand when we think about how price
how the private sector invests
and i think it's something we should uh
feel comfortable with when we when we
recognize that we would benefit from
public sector investment as well
scott uh your any comments from you yeah
i mean i think that
i i really like the distinction between
private government
private failure and and public failure
because in the private sector when
companies and investments fail
the investors lose um and
they learn from those losses by contrast
in the government sector when the
projects fail they're often times
rewarded
uh with more money or more uh
or a change that actually things makes
things worse
not better if you look at the history
again
of so many different programs the the
result of failure
is not uh terminating the program it is
expanding the program and making it
worse down the line
and i don't think for a second that you
can it's just this easy thing to oh
we'll just
insulate them from the bureaucrats uh
time and time again it shows
that that's really not the case um and
again i i hate to kind of go back to
things like the dumping law
but the fact is that when you get in the
weeds of these things when you
set up a bureaucratic agency or a
program
that is designed to work with certain
industries eventually
the bureaucracy becomes captured or
congress gets involved and makes the law
worse
and and the vehicle for providing
whatever it is
uh the protection or the subsidy
actually becomes
uh more distortionary over time and i
and i think that that is a huge
difference of course between the private
sector and the government sector and i
think the other thing again
is when we talk about the net benefits
it is
crucial to really consider all of the
hidden costs
to these programs whether it's political
costs or opportunity costs
or the the capital misallocation and
distortions
um and the the answer there it or the
additional costs from those things are
really critical before you can say aha
we created x y or z and that must be a
net benefit
thank you scott uh question for you
scott at least let's start with you a
simple question
what do you say to those who suggest
that industrial policy
should be done solely through r d
uh tax credits tax credits and of into
research and development
yeah so there's actually a lot of great
studies in r d
tax credit so i think this is a good
example first of all let me say
in general government can change the
level of something whether it's r d or
or the rest
but r d tax credits provide a really
good example of
problems that arise because it turns out
when the r d
tax credit was first provided all of a
sudden
companies were reclassifying things as
r d and so there's a lot of question in
the academic literature about
whether these r d tax credits were
actually uh
worth it in the long run um and and
again this gets to all sorts of kind of
uh questions about uh allocation of
resources and when you provide that tax
credit
all of a sudden it pays to hire a bunch
of accountants and lawyers
to figure out um what is the best way to
capture
that rent and that money is not only can
you
lead to possible ventures that didn't
need to be done
but it's also just money wasted on on
again
lobbying and rent seeking instead of on
productive things like
jobs and actual innovation
so that means you oppose r d tax credit
you oppose them yeah i mean generally
yes
comment from you warren on that question
uh you know they're not my sort of top
priority
proposal among other things because as
as scott just noted i think to a
significant account they lead to just
to an extent a significant extent they
lead more to shifting around
um pools of money being spent already
i do think it's important to note that
that the us in terms of the the tax
incentive it provides for
for research and development um and
investment
uh used to be near the top of the oecd
and is now near the bottom
um and and so that is not per se an
argument for it but but it is to say
that
um you know this is not an area where uh
we're
we're sort of throwing around money
willy-nilly and
uh at the end of the day if it's
something that uh that that we want
businesses to be doing more of uh we we
should make it relatively more
attractive than
uh than things that that that have less
economic value
questions about productivity um
in in particular uh
scott do you agree that uh at least as a
source of concern
that conventionally measured
productivity by the bureau of labor
statistics
over the past 20 years that productivity
growth has
slowed do you do regard that as a source
of concern
uh sort of since uh it was stressed by
oren
well i mean i think that that i think
that
productivity is important and that it's
a
a source of concern but i think that
there's two things
one is uh can the government really
uh fix that issue um and two
um well actually three things excuse me
two
is um are we today measuring
productivity correctly i think there's a
lot of debate right now
uh among academics about whether there's
a lot of kind of hidden productivity
gains that we're not really seeing
because so much of what's uh what's
being
being done in in information technology
and internet and the rest
really is not stuff that that is easily
calculable
despite massive benefits for businesses
and for consumers
and then third is there's a lot of uh
speculation that we could be really on
the cusp of of quite a significant
acceleration
in productivity growth and so you know
those are the types of things that again
you know
that i think caution severe
uh changes to economic policy
based on a a snapshot or a single
economic indicator
a related question for you warren you
can comment on this question but with
respect to productivity another question
came in that
that the trajectory of productivity has
been that it
slowed in the 70s and 80s accelerated in
the 90s
slowed in the arts uh and so the the
questioner is skeptical
that this rise and fall acceleration
deceleration
has anything much to do with whether
there was an industrial policy in place
or whether there wasn't
could you comment on that comment on
productivity generally
yeah and and this is a reason that i
focused specifically on manufacturing
productivity
um as a measure for one thing i think it
avoids a lot of the current concerns
scott was
just describing about output um because
with you know
services and like what is google's you
know the productivity
at google is hard to say um when you're
talking about manufacturing output i
think you have a
a much more concrete and consistent
overtime measure
of productivity in terms of the people
doing the work and the amount of stuff
that comes out
um and in manufacturing you don't see
that up and down what you see is a
a uh fairly steady rate of productivity
growth
and quite strong um through the first
two periods
uh that that you just described uh and
and then a real collapse over
over the last 10 to 15 years um and and
so i just i i want to underscore that
point
as as something that i i think we
haven't been talking about
well it's my fault for not talking about
it more i suppose you know we've been
talking about sort of manufacturing jobs
and so forth
but but i really want to underline again
that the the second of the three things
that make us care about industrial
policy
which is the innovation in productivity
and and the trajectory over time
and the stuff we invest in today the
stuff we're good at now
affects what we can do tomorrow and so
if you
pursue a policy for a long period of
time that says we don't care
potato chips computer chips what's the
difference um
you can in fact find yourself in a
position where you are
less good at making less of the stuff of
the stuff
where you are seeing the innovation and
you could have gotten the productivity
gains
and i think that's that is a quite good
description of what we have in fact been
seeing
any uh coming from you scott on that or
yeah i mean
uh two quick points one again the data
are really clear
um that we actually uh aren't
just simply making uh potato chips that
whether it's aerospace or transportation
or computers
or defense systems or satellites or the
rest
the united states manufacturing sector
is still producing a ton
of stuff and still at the leading edge
of those industries so
i think that's the first issue the
second though is and this is i think a
bigger
issue i have with industrial policy
there's a really big conflict i think
between
the encouraging innovation and
productivity side of things
and the use of industrial policy as a
jobs program
because they really they're in direct
conflict because if you're investing in
the most innovative and productive
uh industries for example that steel
company that only needs
uh 15 workers to make 500 000 tons of
steel
where you're not really creating a
measurable change
to to to jobs to having those
manufacturing jobs that we apparently so
desperately need
on the other hand if you start investing
in low wage low productivity jobs the
ones that would be more stable
and uh and uh the ones that would be
less susceptible to
automation and industrial robots and all
these things that manufacturing
uh owners and factory owners say is
the essential to advanced manufacturing
if you're investing those
other low productivity jobs well you're
not really going to
have again that productivity so it
really strikes me as
kind of you know the the veg-o-matic of
policies it it's somehow going to create
these lara
you know large group of stable jobs but
also this kind of high productivity high
in
innovation high churn industries as well
um and and that um
i think is a bit of a problem right uh
that concludes the q a part of the
evening we've we go into the summations
uh or in uh you're the affirmative so
you go first
seven and a half minutes for your
summation take it away oren
all right well thank you this has been a
fantastic conversation
um i i don't agree with scott any more
than i did but he's given me a couple
things to go read up on at least so
that's
that's always good um i i guess i want
to sort of
walk briefly through the debate as it's
happened and at least describe from my
perspective
where we've ended up um you know scott's
opening statement
uh really focused heavily on data and a
whole
a whole set of claims about um how how
well the u.s manufacturing sector is
doing
i and in particular demonstrating that
by by comparing our performance to other
countries around the world
um since then when i went through what
the data actually shows he
he decided he didn't want to get into a
data fight
uh and then shortly thereafter said that
he was always skeptical of cross-country
comparisons um and and so in fact we
haven't actually ended up
talking a whole lot or resolving this
question
uh of of of whether there is opportunity
within the manufacturing sector
uh beyond at least what what i still see
to be very clear which
which is one uh that output growth has
not kept pace with what we would expect
even for an economy uh of the us's state
as compared to a lot of other developed
economies like germany and japan
switzerland and the share of their
economies that have good manufacturing
jobs
and high levels of manufacturing
innovation and productivity
uh and and that we again are not seeing
the kind of productivity and innovation
in that sector uh that that we could uh
and and that we should want um
instead it seems to me the the debate
has has become
mostly a a public choice debate that is
the question of whether government can
do any of these things
um and and as i said i i certainly agree
that that government's not going to be
uh that the government's not going to be
perfect and it's going to make
lots of big mistakes but the question is
whether we can improve on the status quo
and and i think that's a really
important question to ask and it's a
real
trap that a lot of public choice
arguments fall into
um where where they somehow hypothesize
that that if we don't pursue
the policy i'm proposing uh we somehow
will have fewer public choice
concerns uh and and i think scott sort
of implied that when he posed the
question about
foxconn and whether if my only choices
were nothing or foxconn
uh what would i choose uh in fact
even the nothing five minutes five
minutes if we ask what
nothing would be the the nothing of
today
uh is already an amalgamation of messy
policies created over time by
politicians
uh with with all of those interests that
scott has been raising
uh so so there is no sort of uh
small government no interference uh
paradise to
to be had uh and of course if if scott
could have his way and try to implement
one uh he would have to go through
congress and face the exact same
problems too
and and again end up with a mess so
so an option of public choice not being
a problem
and all of these messes of government
not being a problem isn't on the table
uh whether we do nothing whether we do
what he might propose whether we do what
i might propose
um we are going to have that set of
problems and it seems to me that's
almost a baseline that we need to work
within
um you know as scott's described we have
we have all manner of economic policies
already
uh and unfortunately i i don't think
they're especially well geared
to some of the priorities that um that
we should have
and so uh the the the argument i'm
making
is not that uh if i were czar of the
world here is the perfect thing that
would be
done it's that in the policy making
process as it exists in washington
um recognizing that we have um
an opportunity here recognizing that we
have
an area where markets are not going to
uh
really address the situation at all uh
and therefore believing that at the
margin
uh some efforts to do things like
encourage uh research consortia and fund
them
another of the policies we haven't
talked about at all is on the education
side
feeling comfortable acknowledging that
engineering degrees are more valuable to
us than dance degrees
um those strike me as the sorts of
determinations that
we we actually could and should be
asking
our uh our policymakers to consider
and and so when i step back and ask what
you know what am i actually hoping to
accomplish here
i i think scott's point about what was
it the vitamix of
or the the veggie something of of
industrial policy struck me because
um it highlights like maybe that that i
haven't been as clear about as i should
um which is i don't see a conflict at
all between the high productivity goal
and the lots of
of jobs goal because for me the goal
isn't necessarily
lots of manufacturing jobs the goal is
is a robust manufacturing sector and
high levels of productivity growth and
innovation
and and just to make that concrete if
you imagine a community that has a steel
mill
on the hill outside of town um
in in the world scott's describing where
it becomes extremely productive and
innovative
uh and requires less labor in it that's
actually still a really good outcome
for that community you're going to have
perhaps fewer but
but higher paying jobs you might have
more people coming in
to do some of those jobs you're going to
have more income coming into the
community
and that can then other among other
things support a healthier
uh services sector for for people who
are moving into the services sector
what i worry about is when you say well
we you know we don't care about whether
or not we have
a robust manufacturing sector that plant
can just close up and move somewhere
else
uh and and if that happens the story is
very different if that happens
uh you you don't have the viability of
the service sector or really that
community at all
and so the what we should be pursuing is
not necessarily some arbitrarily high
number of
jobs we should want a manufacturing
sector and an industrial sector which i
said
includes resource extraction includes
infrastructure development
um we we should want a an economy that
has
that robust sector with high levels of
innovation and rising productivity
because of the benefits that that
generates for the rest of the society
in all of those spillovers i've been
talking about in terms of resilience
innovation one minute women and
the kinds of employment in those
industries and and the spillovers for
the health of the communities
in which they operate and if those are
things we value
and i think they are uh and if that's
not something the market's going to
consider
and i think we agree it's not uh then i
think it's something that
that policymakers should consider and
and i'm not proposing a radical overhaul
of public policy
uh compared to most things the
government does these kinds of
uh you know investments are actually
quite small and they can be tested and
ramped up
uh but as compared to our current
attitude which is to have no strategy at
all
uh and what i take to be scott's
preference which is to expect that the
market would deliver a better outcome
uh with with no public consideration of
the direction investment goes
uh it seems to me that that an effort to
to recognize there are certain kinds of
investments that have high social value
and that public policy can play a role
in encouraging them
is is a sensible approach that's going
to address some real problems we have
take advantage of some real
opportunities we have uh and and
ultimately we're down to
to the benefit of the american people
thank you um oren um scott
uh summation from you take it away scott
yeah i
i want to start again just by
reiterating um the
the data on us manufacturing
are are really quite clear um and this
is not
this is actually uh i don't i don't want
to go back into a data fight only
because i
i only had seven minutes but the fact is
that
if you look at what has happened in the
u.s manufacturing sector
in terms of not merely output
particularly
output in core sectors we talk about
resilience and all these things
in durable goods in the rest the these
sectors are
up r d is up investment is
up and fdi is productive even if it is
acquisitions there is still creating
value there
fdi also has as we talked about
spillover effects for local communities
and the rest
so these things if you go into uh
various financial metrics for the metric
manufacturing sector
all of these things show a healthy
sector one that is still productive
furthermore on the resilient side you
know a a few months ago
everybody was screaming about supply
chain resilience supply chain resilience
well the again there we now have seen
how these supply chains have reacted
and they actually again have worked out
pretty well
in the face of absolutely generational
changes in supply and demand
um and so these these factors again
unless there is
some arbitrary magical number in terms
of r
d spending or the rest that i'm not
aware of there's really little evidence
to indicate we need
an industrial policy however you want to
design it however you want to describe
it
to boost the sector overall particularly
when you get
when you look at these very very common
uh trends in jobs in
uh manufacturing sector the economy in
consumption and the rest
that simply argue that a lot of what is
going on in the united states is going
on
everywhere and is going on um not
because of some problems with
de-industrialization or resilience but
because this is a
standard story of economic development
one that has been
backed up by uh boatloads of economic
research
but again i do think it is important to
think about the point here is should we
adopt an industrial policy and again
here
this is what really strikes me as the
problem because when you look at the
history of these industrial policies
it is not simply about oh i'm going to
create this magical r d consortia
the fact is that oran and others want us
to believe that their policies aren't
going to be
like the others they're going to be
designed just like it says in a in a
policy paper of the rest
they'll be insulated from the political
cycles whether it's
the trump administration wanting heavy
manufacturing or now the biden
administration wanting green
manufacturing
they'll be guided by smart altruists who
will have
know everything know which sectors not
drams they'll set they'll invest in the
right sectors and the rest
and um and and and of course that
somehow
economic policies are going to solve
deep-seated
economic and cultural problems that that
exist in america
now as hope as i've hopefully shown
there are a lot of reasons for
skepticism
their skepticism of the problems we
supposedly have
the united states for example is making
good jobs wages
are up communities are adapting
to seismic changes in technology and
trade and the rest
um uh there we should be skeptical of
the industrial policies we could
feasibly implement um and and how many
minutes
policies evolve over time um we also
again need to be skeptical of the
ability of these policies to
fix the problems we really do have and
importantly do better what private
actors
certainly not perfect themselves could
do and again i think the evidence there
certainly weighs against adopting
industrial policy
in fact i think that given the history i
described given
books that have been written on these
subjects well advocates of industrial
policy need to marshal
a lot of proof a lot that prosperity for
all
of all americans really needs industrial
policy again as opposed to other
less targeted economic reforms that
again are really feasible
um advocates like oren really need to
prove that even if we have these things
even if we need them in
theory the same forces that have long
plagued industrial policy efforts won't
happen this time
i don't think that he's come close to
meeting this standard and you know
faith in in their the next generation's
ability to implement them really isn't
going to cut it
and you know i think the the real point
here is there's a common refrain we hear
that my side of this is
is market fundamentalism i'm a
fundamentalist
in my views on on trade or industrial
policy and the rest
but this really isn't true i mean look
we're guided by certain principles
and versed in the economic literature
but but my view
in particular and the negative position
i take in this debate is driven by
decades of experience i mean i don't
reject that market failures exist i
don't reject that government policies
might correct them and and help certain
people in the process
but i reject that industrial policy
adopting these broad
policies that we have in the past will
somehow make things better for the
country
and achieve again prosperity for all
people not just certain groups of people
not just certain uh managers and ceos or
companies
but all americans and it really doesn't
indicate that that would be the case
and again having a long history toiling
in the bowels of the commerce department
and us any dumping law and the rest and
seeing
how the sausage is actually made um it
really
provides a real-world skepticism of our
ability
to tinker in the margins and produce
better outcomes for the country
and again given how well things are
going
right now so can we draw lessons from
the past yes i i think we can
and i think again and again it shows
that this position in the negative is
driven
not by any sort of fundamentalism but by
a pragmatic understanding of our history
and and the potential for these things
to go very very wrong
not just in direct costs but in longer
term costs
in terms of encouraging even worse
policy
down the road so thank you
thank you uh under your seven and a half
and uh
uh that concludes uh the debate
and now jane please open
the final vote again you're voting
finally on the resolution
that to promote prosperity among all
income groups the us government
should adopt an industrial policy
the final vote is open so please cast
your final vote the yes vote
on the resolution gained from 12.73
to 18. that was a gain of 5.45 percent
uh on oren's part defending the
resolution
so that's the number to beat uh the no
vote
gained from 60 to 74.55
a gain of 14.55 points
so the tootsie roll goes to the no
vote uh thank you very much scott thank
you very much oren
for a very informative debate again
that's just a game we play
uh this uh debate will be available on
video and on podcast
for the larger audience uh and so again
uh a great debate a great exchange of
ideas
and we'll see you soon hopefully
in florida on february 18th good night